[APPLAUSE]
JAIME GREEN: All right,
thanks so much for coming in
to talk with us.
So a couple of days
ago, Vogue magazine
published a beautiful
profile of you.
I just want to, as
a way of starting,
read what they wrote about the
book and your main character,
because I think they
captured it pretty--
I'll let someone else
do a little bit of work.
So they said, "when it comes
to fictional single women
in the city, there's a
few obvious touchstones.
Andrea," who's the main
character of All Grown Up,
"is Sex in the City's
Carrie Bradshaw,
if Carrie drank bourbon
neat, hated herself
for not writing novels, and
was something of a nihilist.
Andrea is Girls' Hannah
Horvath, if Hannah
had stuck with that one awful
copywriting job for a decade,
and had become humble
and expansive and soulful
in the process.
But if there's one character
Andrea most resembles,
it's Phoebe
Waller-Bridge's Fleabag,
not because, as
Attenberg sums it up,
'single lady drinking and
screwing,'" which I think
we'll hear more
about in a minute.
JAMI ATTENBERG: Yeah.
JAIME GREEN: OK.
"But because in both cases,
recklessness and mordant
wit are the cover for
deeply entrenched,
slowly revealed trauma--
pain that only gets more painful
the more we learn about it."
So that's one-- or a few
ways of describing Andrea.
How would you describe her?
JAMI ATTENBERG: I
think she's funny.
I think that she's
self-deprecating.
I think that she is
searching for happiness.
She's somebody who
has had the same job--
given up her art
career for a really--
forever-- and has a
job in advertising,
and sort of secretly
regrets giving it up,
but just can't seem to
find her way back to it.
She's somebody who is capable
of being a good friend,
but also a bad friend.
She's both good and
bad, that's the thing
that I really like about
her, in terms of a writer.
It's just very
entertaining to write
somebody who fucks up some of
the time, or a lot of the time.
JAIME GREEN: So
it's entertaining.
Is it ever hard to watch
her make a bad decision?
When you're like, no, no, no!
I can see it go that way.
JAMI ATTENBERG: No,
that's when it gets good,
that's when it gets
really interesting.
Yeah.
That's when you
make things happen
and you force these
characters to really reckon
with the reality.
JAIME GREEN: Yeah.
Before we dive more
into questions,
do you want to
read from the book?
JAMI ATTENBERG: Yeah.
Sure.
How about starting off with
something really dirty.
Is that all right?
JAIME GREEN: That is fine.
JAMI ATTENBERG: We have a lot
of women in the audience here,
so I was like, I'm going for it.
JAIME GREEN: Yeah.
JAMI ATTENBERG: So this is
from a chapter called "Chloe."
and a lot of the
chapters in the book
are actually named after
women, and I just really wanted
that to-- even though on this
section I'm about to read
is about a man.
But I really wanted to
make sure that there
was a really strong
female energy that
was running through this book.
"We meet at a mutual friend's
barbecue, Barron and I.
Our mutual friend's name is Deb,
and she had told me in advance
to look out for him.
Newly single, she had texted.
Like "newly" newly?
Fresh out of the womb?
I texted back.
Successful, creative,
smart, she texted.
A catch!, I texted.
In a year he'll be
a catch, she texted.
Right now, he's a good time.
Am I not good
enough for a catch?
I texted.
She didn't text
back for six hours.
Sorry, she texted.
Work.
There was another pause.
Am I mistaken that you
want to have a good time?
she texted.
I'd wanted to argue so
badly, but I couldn't.
Barron and I have an
extremely long conversation
about potato salad
because Deb has
made two kinds of potato
salad, the creamy kind
and the vinegary kind.
It is dumb, jokey conversation--
kind of worthless,
actually-- but he looks at
me with obvious interest
and desire.
I get a little hot in my pants.
He has a shaved head, the early
male pattern baldness shave.
He cleans his glasses a
lot and I point this out
and he shrugs and says, I
can't stand fingerprints.
I take his glasses from
him, breathe on them,
and wipe them on the
end of my silky shirt.
Like new, I say,
and hand them back.
You're helpful, he says.
At some point in
the conversation,
we realized we lived 10
blocks from each other.
Convenient, I say, and grin.
Deb lives in a garden
apartment and there
are children running in
and out of the garden
and the apartment.
And one of them
screeches and I shudder.
Children, ugh!
I say.
I have a child, Barron says.
Just because I don't
like children doesn't
mean I can't like you, I
say, and I touch his arm
and feel like both a failure
and a success at the same time,
because even though I've
already fucked this up,
I was probably
supposed to, anyway.
Two normal people walk
away from each other right
then and there, but
instead, he gives me
a ride home and parks in front
of a fire hydrant on my street
and then we make out in
the front seat of his car
while I ignore the presence
of the child seat in the back.
[LAUGHTER]
He's really aggressive.
Tongue in the mouth, ear,
throat, squeezing my breasts
hard through my blouse.
I'm both mortified and aroused.
I put my hand on his
dick through his pants
and he stops and says,
you're the first person
I've been with besides
my ex-wife in 12 years.
I say, whoa, that's a
lot for a first date!
And he says, this wasn't a date.
And I feel suddenly
hoarse and damaged.
OK, I say, I'm done.
I put my hand on the door,
but I give him a few seconds
to apologize, which he does.
He says, I'm sorry, I
don't know what I'm doing.
I don't know if I'm
coming or going.
I'm having every
emotion at once.
He takes my hand and kisses it.
You're beautiful, he says.
You're beautiful and sexy and
you should let me take you out
and we'll do this right.
Toxic, says my co-worker,
Nina, on Monday morning.
Drop him immediately.
He texts me on
Wednesday and asks me
if I want to have dinner
with him on Friday night.
I say I have plans, because
I'm trying to play hard to get,
which has absolutely
never worked
for me in my entire life.
He says he can't see me
on Saturday because he
has his daughter that night.
I fold instantly.
I'll move something
around, I say.
We pick a restaurant
in the neighborhood,
but as a pretense,
because we both know
what is going to happen.
We've been texting about
the things we're going
to do to each other for days.
It's terrible and
it's all I want.
On Friday, I take off
work early and get
groomed in various ways.
Then I go to Dean and
Deluca and buy blueberries
and then I allow myself the
indulgence of a MoMA visit.
I pay $25 and go
up to the top floor
and wend my way
through the museum.
Eventually I found
myself lingering
around their
permanent collection.
All that work those
people made for decades,
and here's their greatest
hits, one or two pieces
plucked from storage.
Better the one piece than
none at all, I guess.
I miss painting.
Even the fumes I miss.
I spent the past 13
years looking for a smell
to replace it.
Hours later, I'm smelling all
of him, his fumes, a cocktail
at the bar before
our reservation.
I am 38 and he is 42.
I'm just starting
over, he tells me.
Sometimes I feel like
I'm done, I tell him.
Dinner's fast, but I
still try to enjoy myself
because I love food.
At the weirdest, darkest, most
stressful moments of my life,
I always make sure
to have a nice meal.
I order a steak.
I want it rare, I
tell the waitress.
Like, bloody red.
Carnivore, he says.
That's me, I say.
We drink two glasses
of wine each and I say,
you know what we
should have done?
And he says, gotten the bottle?
I never plan that right, I
say, and he says, me neither.
And we smile at each other.
Let's just get along, I think.
All we have to do is get along.
We walked to my apartment, not
his, which he claims is a mess.
He's wearing a hat and a
chambray shirt and shorts
and loafers and he
has an easy stride.
I'm wearing a black
dress, loose and summery,
and I feel pretty and
intellectually engaged
after my day of art.
Also, I feel drunk.
At home there is
bourbon and I tell him
that while we walk
and he tells me
I'm a dream girl--
like he literally says,
I feel like you were sent to me
as a present from the heavens
above.
And I laugh so
hard, but I love it.
When we get to my studio,
he surveys it and nods.
The art, the stacks of books,
the pots and pans dangling
dramatically from a ceiling
rack, while I shakily,
excitedly pour us
two bourbons, neat.
We clink glasses and
then drink quickly.
This is so exciting, he says.
I'm so excited!
[LAUGHTER]
I boldly take off my dress.
I'm just standing there
naked in front of him.
I love all the curves, he says.
Hips, yes.
He is nodding at
me, approving of me.
I realize I am desperate for
his approval, this man who
was married, this father of one,
this someone else's, now mine.
He takes off his hat and then
a shirt and then his pants.
He is pale white
and nearly hairless,
and I realize he has
trimmed his pubic hair.
Did you-- I point to his crotch.
I thought I was
supposed to, he says.
I read it in GQ.
I really haven't seen
it before, I say.
I think I went a little
too far, he says.
I waxed my chest, too.
It hurt.
I waxed too.
I say.
Just here, though.
I motion to my crotch.
It looks nice on you, he says.
Normal.
Our confessions done, we
kiss and then he's on me
and it's fast.
It's happening, it's on.
He bends me over on my couch and
from behind begins to pound me.
There's a mirror
nearby and I can
see that he's watching himself,
watching his facial expression.
This moment has so
little to do with me.
After a while, we
try another position.
And then another position.
And then another one.
Can we go back?
I say.
What Huh?
He gasps, pushes his
glasses up, looks at me.
I like what we're doing
before, like 10 minutes ago.
Hold on, he says, and he
stops to clean his glasses
with my nearby underpants.
Then we rearrange our
bodies to the old position
and we move very slowly
and it's fantastic,
but then he starts to speed up.
And he goes faster
and harder and it
feels like he's trying to
murder me with his dick.
And I say, slow
down a little, baby!
And he says, I can't, I'm going
to come, don't make me stop!
So I don't, because this
is his first time having
sex with another person other
than his wife in 12 years
and it's with me and I want
him to remember it as great.
I let him pound me for another
minute and he orgasms loud--
certainly loud enough to be
heard from the street below--
and he's just so
proud of himself.
And almost immediately
I begin to hate him,
but I also desire
him even more, too."
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks.
So romantic.
JAIME GREEN: There's something--
at the end of that scene,
Andrea says--
about how it was wonderful
and she loved it,
and she also hates
him a little bit.
I feel like that's
a reaction she
has often throughout the book.
It's not that she just
hates a lot of people,
but something about--
is it strong feelings
or vulnerability
from other people?
She has this-- she gets
repulsed by something.
JAMI ATTENBERG: She doesn't
want to deal with it.
She doesn't want to
deal with things.
She doesn't have a middle
ground a lot of the times.
There's not a lot of--
there is a lot of nuance
to this book, but in a way,
there's not a lot of
nuance to her life.
But she's also, on the
other hand, she's almost--
she's 38 in that and
she's basically almost 40
for most of the book in
the present tense timeline.
And she kind of
knows what she wants.
JAIME GREEN: Yeah.
JAMI ATTENBERG: And that's cool
to actually know what you want.
And she doesn't-- she's
not hard to deal with.
She just, in her mind,
is like, well, I'm
not interested in
babies and I'm not
interested in getting
married or settling down
in any kind of way.
But still, part of her
recognizes that she wants some
sort of, I don't know if
it's validation from society,
but she wants to figure out
how to be more grown up,
how to be an adult.
And she can't--
she's never fit into that
conventional timeline
or those conventional
milestones.
So what is she going to--
she keeps seeking it, in a way.
JAIME GREEN: Yeah.
So she's not choosing the
markers on the old-fashioned
or just traditional path of
a career that you advance in
and a partner and marriage
and babies and a house and all
that.
That's how we know
we're grown up.
And she doesn't
want those things.
And so then she--
she's a grown-up age,
she has a grown-up job,
she has an apartment.
But she just doesn't know how
else to measure grownup-ness.
JAMI ATTENBERG: And really, the
book is kind of about her, one,
figuring out how to be happy.
Not just her, but every
character in the book
is sort of striving for that
grownup-ness and that maturity
and also the self-satisfaction
that comes with age.
And then two,
well, I don't know,
I think that's really
what the book is about.
That she's really
seeking what's going
to be the next step for
her and how to be happy.
JAIME GREEN: Because
you write about how
she feels like she's stuck.
Her life hasn't changed
in 10 years or so.
JAMI ATTENBERG: Yeah.
JAIME GREEN: You said earlier
that she knows what she wants,
she knows what she doesn't want.
But she also-- it
seems like she doesn't
know what she wants from her
life, in terms of that shape.
One of the recurring
things in the book
is her conversations with her
therapist, or her thinking
about her therapist, and how she
doesn't want to go to therapy
or does.
But there's one section where
she's thinking that she just
doesn't know what she
wants, that she feels stuck,
but she doesn't
know what she wants.
And one of the ways
I've heard about writing
fiction or writing a plot
is that you figure out
what your character wants
and you put them on a path
and you put some
obstacles in the way.
But since she struggles
to know what she wants,
was it hard to propel
her through the story?
JAMI ATTENBERG: Well, I
think that one way that I
deal with that is
that I show all
of these flashback
chapters, where
you see who she was as a kid.
There's scenes of her
when she's 13, chapters
when she's 13 and
chapters where she's
16 and chapters when she's in
her 20s and early 30s, as well.
And so all of those,
I think those things
propel the story forward
because you get to see--
I wanted to have just a fully
realized character where
you knew everything about her.
And I also wanted to be
the story of being a woman,
as well.
And the way that
different things
that have happened your life
can impact you as a woman.
Although I do think that men
will also enjoy this book
and can read this book and
should read this book, in fact.
JAIME GREEN: Yeah, there's a
lot, definitely a lot to learn.
And also, she's just--
she's interesting
and she's human.
And what a sad state
of the world that we
have to fight for
books about women
to be seen as
applying to everyone.
But it's true.
It's there.
JAMI ATTENBERG: Yeah.
JAIME GREEN: Let's talk a
little bit about the structure
because you've mentioned
it a couple of times.
The chapters, which all have
different names, and the way
they jump around in time, it's
a really interesting structure.
How would you describe it?
JAMI ATTENBERG: When
I was writing it,
there were different
story cycles within it
and there were
different topics that I
wanted to address that I felt
fit into certain categories.
So there's a couple
of stories that
fall under the "where she
lives, apartment" category.
And then she has
a best friend who
she watches get
married and have a baby
and have a more, quote
unquote, "adult life moments"
happen to her.
And so there are all these
little cycles that I--
I don't know if other
people would notice them,
but I know they're there and
I felt like they sort of--
it's a very short novel,
and I think that they
make the novel feel bigger.
But then beyond that, yeah,
it just switches time a lot
and part of it is
because when you
think about the most important
things that ever happened
to you in your life, like
you made a top 10 list,
it wouldn't be in
chronological order.
You might say number
one is getting married,
but number two is getting into
a fistfight with your neighbor
in the seventh grade.
Number three is getting
your heart broken.
And number four is
going to college.
So you would be surprised
if you sat down and tried
to make that list.
There's just not a
linear path to it.
And so I didn't see a linear
path for her in this book,
either.
JAIME GREEN: Yeah,
and we also see--
there's one of those cycles-- or
three lines that's popping up--
is a little bit chronological.
She goes from 38
to, I guess, 41?
40?
And the flashbacks and bits from
her past are informing that.
She has this memory
about the dinner parties
that her mother used to
throw when she was 17.
And then as present day
Andrea is dealing with that,
we get the scene where we
get to see what happens,
as she's remembering
it, and figuring out
how it fits into her life.
And so even as all of those
bigger arcs are going through,
each of the chapters has a sort
of self-contained feeling, too.
JAMI ATTENBERG:
Like a short story.
JAIME GREEN: Yeah.
JAMI ATTENBERG:
They were all kind
of originally short
stories and I wrote them
all as short stories.
And then, at some
point, they had
to get altered because it was
clear it was really a novel.
And so they had to be--
I had to move things around
a little bit in service
of the bigger
picture of the novel.
I couldn't keep
repeating things.
But the other thing is,
I just really wanted
to make an interesting book.
I wanted it to be interesting
to read, where people were like,
oh, it's not what I expected
at all, and this happens here
and this happens here.
So literally every
chapter, you're just like,
I don't know what's
going to happen next.
I don't know where she
is in this exact moment.
I wanted to have that
experience of it feeling really
surprising and fresh and new.
And I was also thinking about
the way people read now.
And I wasn't interested in
writing these long and lovely
sentences.
I was sort of over
sentences, which
is such a pretentious and
terrible thing to say.
But this is kind of
my post-sentence book,
which makes sense to me.
But I really was thinking
about how everybody
wants all the
information right now,
and so I wanted
to just make sure
that it always felt like
you were finding out
exactly what's happening.
And I wanted it to feel true,
so all those things, to me--
the subject matter and
the themes and the form
all integrate.
JAIME GREEN: Yeah.
So another thing about Andrea
is she sees herself as a failed
artist, or a former artist.
She went to art school and
then, when she was about 20,
left and bailed and has, in
some ways, abandoned that art.
Although, in the really
beautiful first chapter,
I think, we learn that,
in her Williamsburg
loft with her view of the
Empire State Building, every day
or multiple times a
day, she draws or paints
the Empire State Building.
But it's this
secret, hidden thing
that feels very disconnected
from the rest of her life.
And one of the
things she says when
she's talking about
going to galleries
is saying she can tell
when an artist is lying
or an artist is telling the
truth, which is what you just
said about this book.
You wanted it to be true.
Is that a sixth sense
that you feel like you
have about other novels or art?
JAMI ATTENBERG: I say that,
but you could just as easily--
what is true for me
is not necessarily
true for other people.
And their art also--
somebody might feel that
way about this book.
In a way, it kind
of doesn't matter,
because whatever you're going
to get out of this book,
you're going to get out of
this book, or any piece of art.
It's important to
me, but I don't
care if it's important
to anyone else.
JAIME GREEN: That's fair, yeah.
It had to feel true to you
as you were writing it.
JAMI ATTENBERG: Yeah.
JAIME GREEN: True is also--
JAMI ATTENBERG: It's my art.
JAIME GREEN: Yeah, totally.
And true is an interesting sort
of goal in a work of fiction
also.
Obviously, there's
emotional truth and things
that feel true.
JAMI ATTENBERG: I think fiction
can somehow make something
feel more real than nonfiction.
Because you have
access to things.
You have access to her secrets.
And you have access to
her interior thoughts.
And you know everything about--
you know what she was like
when she was a little kid.
Whereas if you were
interviewing her, if she was--
a newspaper profile or
something like that, you really
would only be able to know x
amount of things about her.
JAIME GREEN: That's funny
because your last book, Saint
Mazie, was built, in part,
on imagined interviews.
So that one, you had the
story of Mazie's life
and then a contemporary person
trying to piece it together
and doing interviews.
I don't really have a question.
It's an interesting--
JAMI ATTENBERG: It was a
theme also in that book
because it was based
on a real person
and there wasn't very
much information about her
in the real world.
And so it was initially
quite frustrating to me
because I wanted to
know more about her.
But then it was really freeing
because I realized that I
can invent whatever I wanted.
And it was a lesson
to me that we aren't
entitled to know everything.
That we aren't actually entitled
to other people's truths.
And there's very
few pictures of her.
I ended up finding a picture
of that person after the fact.
Really, there was
probably a handful
of pictures that were ever
taken because this person was--
what she was based
on was-- helped
the homeless for decades.
And she was a little
too busy saving lives
to worry about taking a selfie.
I also think that our society is
a hugely confessional society.
And yet, at the same time,
so much of that confession
is done on the internet.
I think we both know
that everyone always
seems happier on the internet
than they actually are.
JAIME GREEN: I don't know
what you're talking about.
JAMI ATTENBERG: So yes, I was
thinking about all those things
when I was writing it.
What we're entitled
to or not entitled to
JAIME GREEN: But then
with Andrea, in this book,
we end up being entitled
to sort of everything?
She doesn't have any
secrets from the reader.
JAMI ATTENBERG:
Yeah, that's true.
But it's fiction.
JAIME GREEN: Yeah.
And so circling back
to that idea of truth,
something that you've
written about and talked
about in the past
is how frustrating
it can be when people
make assumptions
that your writing
is autobiographical.
For two books ago,
for The Middlesteins,
which centers around a
character who's very obese,
you've said that when you
were on book tour for that,
people would meet you and be
surprised that you weren't also
obese, because they were--
JAMI ATTENBERG: They were
like, you're not fat.
And I'm like, thank you.
JAIME GREEN: I invented things.
Which can be-- the
whole point is that you
invent things and are creative.
And that seems like it's
been really frustrating.
JAMI ATTENBERG: But that's
how I've gotten to the place,
for sure, where I'm
like, it's just my art.
It's just my thing.
And so I have to learn
how-- it is frustrating,
just on a personal
day-to-day level
of having people say
messed up things to you.
But it also has helped me to
have a remove from my books,
or forced me to have
a remove from my books
and a specific kind
of way where I'm like,
it doesn't matter
what they think.
I want people to
love my writing.
I write it so that it's--
I write it for me
first, but I also
know that ultimately I want
an audience to read this.
I want them to enjoy it
and love it or hate it
or just feel
something, feel deeply.
But I also know that I can't
take it too personally when
people don't get it.
I don't know.
You just don't
know what people--
you don't know their stories.
You don't know their lives.
You don't know what
it meant to them
or how it triggered
something in them.
JAIME GREEN: Yeah.
And them thinking that it's
autobiographical in nature
doesn't necessarily mean that
it's less affecting to them.
JAMI ATTENBERG: It's
how they're reading it.
Again, because
everyone just assumes--
we're all just documenting
everything all the time,
so people are just like--
I think it's easy for people
to want to make that leap.
I just don't really enjoy
consuming art that way.
And I don't want people to
consume my art that way.
JAIME GREEN: Yeah.
JAMI ATTENBERG: But
I can't control it.
JAIME GREEN: Well, it also--
if people consume
your art that way,
they start making assumptions
about you and about your life.
And you're like, that's
not my experience.
Because in some ways, on
the very surface of things,
you do share some aspects
of your life with Andrea.
Living in Williamsburg--
JAMI ATTENBERG: Yeah, she
feels like a neighbor.
JAIME GREEN: Yeah.
JAMI ATTENBERG: Like
I knew the landscape.
JAIME GREEN: Yeah.
She--
JAMI ATTENBERG: The same
with The Middlesteins.
I knew where it was set
and everything like that.
But I feel like there's
five million books that
are set in New York.
And authors live in New York.
I don't know if everybody
gets that question.
JAIME GREEN: I don't know.
Yeah.
I mean--
JAMI ATTENBERG: It is a
very popular question.
JAIME GREEN: She is
sort of demographically
pretty similar to you in
a lot of ways, I think?
JAMI ATTENBERG: I don't know.
I look at her life and
I would never want it.
JAIME GREEN: Well yeah.
That's what I was
going to ask, but I
wonder if she's, in some ways,
a diverged parallel universe
version of you.
Because the big difference
is, she has given up her art
and feels sort of consumed
and troubled by that.
And you, your life
is making your art.
JAMI ATTENBERG: Yeah.
As I said, to me, it has always
felt like she was a neighbor.
There was an apartment
building that I actually
went to go visit
because I was thinking
about moving out of
the apartment building
that I lived in.
And it was five
blocks away and it
had the same view as my view.
And I always remember that.
So I never think of
it as parallel lives.
I really think of it as
five blocks away life.
And I was like, this is where--
somebody is going to move into
this apartment that's not me.
I remember thinking that.
Who is the person that
moves into this apartment?
And that was probably
five or six years ago.
And then when I was writing
this book and setting it,
I was imagining the person
who lived in that apartment.
I know the terrain.
JAIME GREEN: Yeah.
It's helpful.
I know that some
writers who will--
if they write in a city
that they've never been
to, they'll--
oh, now it sounds like
product placement,
because I was going to
say they use Google Maps
and use Street View to see it.
I'm sorry.
[LAUGHTER]
But you're writing
it in a neighborhood
that you've lived
in and it feels--
you're not name dropping
cafes or anything,
but I feel like the
streets are real
and the place is real, too.
JAMI ATTENBERG: That's good.
I'll take that as a compliment.
JAIME GREEN: I
would love to talk
a little bit about Andrea's
relationship with art, though.
Because I feel like
that's one of the most--
it's one of the big
sadnesses in her life
and she feels like it's
too late in a lot of ways.
So first, did you decide
to make her an artist?
Or did she sort of
come that way to you?
JAMI ATTENBERG: Yes, she
showed up as an artist.
I think the part
of it is that I've
had jobs where I worked
in corporate America
before as a freelancer.
And I didn't even
realize that this
is why I was doing this
until-- but now you're
like my 20th interview, so
I've had to dig into my brain
and figure out why I was
doing what I was doing.
Can't we just write
a book and let it be?
No, we must dissect it over
and over and over again.
JAIME GREEN: Sorry.
JAMI ATTENBERG: But no,
I have a recollection
of when I worked in
different offices
doing freelance work,
sometimes creative.
I've done online
content development
and some copywriting
and things like that.
But I was doing this
as I was writing books.
Because a lot of my books--
this is my sixth book
and like the first three
did not sell very well, so I was
always writing and freelancing.
And then I would meet people
who were also creative people--
either artists or writers--
but they were all
in in the office.
And they were like,
you're a real writer.
And I was like,
who's that person?
Same as the person
living in that house.
Who's that person who
says, oh, once I was this
and now I'm not anymore.
That was interesting
to me as well.
And how did it feel?
How's it feel?
And also I was
really glad that I
made the choices that I made,
even though it was really hard
and an exceptional
financial struggle for me.
And I was 40 years
old and I was still
couch surfing before my
fourth book came out.
I was really broke.
But I couldn't do
it any other way.
I had to-- it was
really important to me
to keep pursuing it.
In a way, I think it is--
again, I don't think of
it as parallel lives,
but I have a friend who read
this book and he was like,
oh, it's like your
worst nightmare.
[LAUGHTER]
If that's helpful.
JAIME GREEN: Yeah.
But on the one hand, Andrea--
it's a huge sadness
and loss in her life.
But she also realizes
that the life
of sacrifice and
rejection for art
isn't necessarily
what she wanted.
I'm not sure she made
the wrong decision.
JAMI ATTENBERG: Right, right.
Well there's a character
in the book name Matthew
who is an artist, and he's
all in on being an artist.
And I honestly feel
like if there's anyone
that I identify with
in the book with,
it's that person more
than anybody else.
I get him more.
I got him instantly,
where I didn't even
have to dive very
deep and I just
knew exactly where
he was coming from.
Where you're kind of like, oh,
well, this is what I'm doing.
I'm here.
I'm never going to
really get there.
Because I've been there,
I've for sure been there.
I think my intention is
for her to somehow find
her way back to it.
And when I think about the
outside universe for the book,
I think, oh, yeah,
she'll figure out
some way to get back into
it a little bit more.
As I said, this book is
about her finding happiness.
And I wanted to
write a book that
was about a single
woman that was not
looking for the marriage or the
children or anything like that.
And so once you wipe
that equation out,
it's like, what is it then?
What is the thing that's
really going to make her happy?
And so I am hoping that
she finds her way to that.
And also, a recognition
that your friends
your family can be
wonderful, and maybe you
have to be more
connected with them, too.
JAIME GREEN: Yeah.
That even if it's not a
romantic partner and children,
it's still about finding
the people around you
and building that.
JAMI ATTENBERG: Yeah.
There's all kinds of
partnerships to be had.
JAIME GREEN: We're
going to open it up
for questions in a minute.
We've got a microphone
over there if anyone--
if you want to ask a question,
just go stand behind it
and then I'll know that
that's why you're there.
I was rereading
the book this week
and I finished it
yesterday, which
was International
Women's Day, and--
yes.
And it struck me, in
that context, how--
the book, in that context,
felt much more explicitly
political and feminist to me.
That I saw so much of what
Andrea was fighting against.
The sort of prescribed path
of women as wives and mothers
and that that's the goal.
And that her personal struggle--
I saw the huge social leading
up to it and everything.
And I see that she's
finding a lot of freedom
in resisting that
prescribed path,
but also gets lost
in some ways, too.
And this is not in
the neighborhood of
"can women have it all?"
JAMI ATTENBERG: I keep
getting asked that question.
I'm like, I don't know!
JAIME GREEN: But she's
not even trying to.
JAMI ATTENBERG:
That's right, yeah.
JAIME GREEN:
Apparently, the original
"can women have it all?" was
just a job and kids, and not
even all the other
awful assumptions.
But she's sort of--
things are harder
for her because she's
trying to figure out her own
path and her own way of being
grown up if that checklist
is being grown up.
So I guess what I want
to ask is, what is--
sorry, it sounds
so cheesy, but I
think the answer will be good.
What does being grown up
mean to you if it's not
that old-fashioned
path of adulthood?
JAMI ATTENBERG: It's
different, right?
It's different.
I've spent a lot
of time thinking
about it because I
had to have an answer.
JAIME GREEN: If you're
going to call the book that.
JAMI ATTENBERG: That's right.
I had to know how I
felt about it, even
though how she feels
about it is different.
For me personally, it's
about taking responsibility
for the choices that I make
and knowing why I'm making them
and just really owning
my life decisions.
And yeah, that's it.
That's what it is
for me, to know
why I'm doing what I'm doing
and be able to stand behind it.
JAIME GREEN: Cool.
JAMI ATTENBERG: Yeah.
You can have that,
also, if you want.
It could be your
definition, too.
JAIME GREEN: I like that.
JAMI ATTENBERG: It
could be everybody
in the room's definition.
But see, that's the thing.
It's a very subtle, nuanced
kind of thing, right?
But it's actually real because
you can have all those--
you could have a baby
and that does not
mean you're a grown up at all.
You can buy a house
and that does not
mean you're a grown up at all.
And I think it's really about
making the adult choices.
JAIME GREEN: That's good.
Got a question.
AUDIENCE 1: Hi.
Thank you, Jami.
And also Jaime.
This has been a
lovely conversation.
So what seems really
interesting about a book
like this is that it keeps--
once you've written
it and finished,
it keeps on existing in the
world with different contexts.
So yesterday,
International Women's Day,
I feel actually much closer to
the characters and kind of love
them a little bit
more, even when
I'm grossed out by their
decisions or I want to say,
please grow up.
Or whatever that is.
So I guess I wonder, for you,
what is the post-book writing
process for you?
Are you interested in keeping
to talk about it afterwards
and how it relates to current
events and things like that?
Or are you just done with it?
You said you've
done 20 interviews,
so I wonder how that is for you.
JAMI ATTENBERG: I've
done 20 interviews,
but the book only just
came out two days ago.
So I actually have a ways to go.
I have two months of touring.
It's always
interesting to see how
you feel about the book at
the beginning of the tour
versus how you feel about
it at the end of the tour,
and how I will feel about
it six months from now.
It's going to be
a different thing.
But I know that--
it was a hesitation, on my
part, to write this book.
Because I was like,
if I write this book,
then I have to freaking
talk about this stuff
for like-- if the
book does well,
then you talk about
it for a year or two.
It just keeps going.
And I've found, even now,
The Middlesteins came out
five years ago and I still get
asked about it in interviews.
Which is great,
and it's wonderful
if you get to have
a book like that.
But you have to just know that
it's a different kind of job,
but it becomes your job.
But I'm happy to--
I wrote this during
the 2016 election.
I started in 2015 and I
finished it in June of 2016.
So there's a lot of
issues in this book
that I really wanted her--
I like her because she
can talk about anything,
because she's got--
she's seen it all.
She's been there.
And she's really
wide-eyed and she's smart.
So I'm willing to go for
a ride for a little while,
then I'm going to have
to do something new.
But I haven't been able
to really shake her.
I do think about her and
I'm ready to talk about her.
But I have complicated
feelings about her
because sometimes she really
is terrible and screws up.
And then sometimes
she's really great
and she's just a human being.
Everybody is right and
wrong in this book.
Everybody screws
up in this book.
And the only way
through it is just--
you have to just
keep going through.
The hardest part
will be, for sure,
is preparing for
people to judge her.
[SIGHS]
Yeah, it's hard.
But I think it's going to be OK.
[LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE 2: Hi.
I have a question that's a
little bit about your own life.
But I know that you did a lot
of your writing of your books
over the years in an
apartment in Brooklyn, right?
In a building with all these
other people and artists
and whatever.
And now you live a lot
of the year in a house
in a place that is not New York
City with the air around you.
So I was just wondering how that
changes your writing process
or your creative process or--
was any of this book
written not in New York?
JAMI ATTENBERG: A lot
of it was written--
AUDIENCE 2: Oh, yeah?
JAMI ATTENBERG: A lot of it.
The final third of it was
written in New Orleans.
AUDIENCE: So did it change?
JAMI ATTENBERG: And a lot of
it was written on the road.
Not a lot of it was
written in New York City.
Three weeks of it were written
at a residency in upstate New
York.
And then some of it was
written in the fall.
But I was on tour, so it
was like my little present
to myself that I could
work on this book
while I was writing when I
didn't want to talk to anyone.
It kept me company.
And so the thing is that
I'm happier in New Orleans.
So I don't know.
I'm always going to write.
That's the thing
I've learned, right?
I'm always going to write.
But so I just wanted
to be happier.
Now I'm happier.
So how will that
impact my writing?
Who knows?
Maybe I'll write something
really sweet next time.
But I don't think so.
AUDIENCE 3: Jaime didn't
really ask you about this,
so I thought I would.
So I really enjoyed reading
about the protagonist.
But at the same time
there was this flip side
with her brother and
her sister-in-law
and this dying baby that
really pulled me in.
And it was a very--
it felt like a very
different plot.
And I was wondering, do
you feel like those two
found a different way to grow
up or did they not manage it?
Because their
relationship is sort
of breaking apart by the end.
I'm curious how you feel
about them growing up.
JAMI ATTENBERG: Well, they
were sort of the model for--
her brother and his
wife, they have a baby
who was born terminally ill.
And they end up leaving New York
and moving to New Hampshire.
This is covered very
early on in the book,
so I'm not giving anything away.
And they leave and she feels
really disconnected from them
and distant from them.
And it's really hard
for them to survive
and it takes an impact
on their relationship.
I think that they're--
I don't know about him, but I
feel like the sister-in-law--
to me, she's the most grown up--
the brother's wife, the
mother of this dying baby.
She seems to be the one
who's really holding it
together and really trying to--
she's taking care of
the family financially
and she's just devoted
herself emotionally to it.
If I had think about who I
liked the most in this book,
I like her.
I like her a lot.
I respect her.
I would want her to be somebody
that I knew in my life.
But I also love all
these characters
for different reasons.
I think they're all kind of--
I don't know, I'm charmed by
all of them in their ways,
even when they're messed up.
I did want to show somebody
who was really kind
of a role model-ish character.
I liked her a lot.
JAIME GREEN: And she's
also able to call
Andrea out more than
maybe almost anyone else
for her own--
the ways that Andrea
is avoiding life.
JAMI ATTENBERG: Yeah.
There's a scene where
she calls Andrea out.
And it was really interesting
because I had a friend--
I had some early
readers read it,
who are people who are creative
people, but they're not--
they write, but
they're not novelists.
And so they just
read it and then
they give me a very
visceral, emotional reaction.
They don't give me notes.
And so one of my friends read it
and she is married with a kid.
And she really did
not like Andrea.
She really had
problems with her.
And then I was talking
to my editor about it
and she said, I think we need
Greta, the sister-in-law,
we need her to yell
at Andrea more.
It's actually about a space
for the audience to yell.
To be like, thank god that
she's yelling at her and saying,
you are sucking right now.
Can you please step up
and be a real human being?
So I went back and
rewrote it and made it
a harsher interaction.
JAIME GREEN: Yeah.
It also takes some of the
pressure off the reader, then,
because we don't have to worry
that the whole book thinks
that what Andrea is doing is OK.
We're like, it's OK.
Jami sees it.
She's got [? someone to. ?]
JAMI ATTENBERG:
Yeah, I guess so.
But also, it's OK if the reader
feels frustrated with her
anyway.
I don't know.
I've had people read
this book and be like,
I totally get her and love her
and she's awesome and great.
And then I have people
read this book and be like,
she is the worst, but
the book's really good.
I get a lot of, I hate her,
but the book's really good.
I don't know why we're supposed
to love our characters anyway.
JAIME GREEN: Yeah.
I feel like as long as we're
OK spending time with them.
And she's fascinating
to spend time with.
JAMI ATTENBERG: Yeah,
that's what you want,
who you're going
to spend time with.
There was like some review of it
where they called her mildly--
what was it?
Mildly annoying or
mildly something.
And I was like, I would
actually hang out with somebody
who is kind of mildly annoying.
If you think about all
your friends, you're like,
I got a couple friends
that are mildly annoying.
But they have other cool things.
And also, sometimes
we like to go out
with people that
are mildly annoying
so then we can bitch
about them afterwards.
JAIME GREEN: So just to wrap up.
When you're in the process
of writing something new,
do you read at the
same time or do you
have to shut out other voices?
JAMI ATTENBERG: Say it
one more time, sorry?
JAIME GREEN: When you're in the
process of writing something
new, do you read
a lot or do you--
JAMI ATTENBERG: Oh, no.
I read a lot, yeah.
But I have to be really choosy.
And as I've written
more books, I've
gotten more particular
about it and not wanting--
sometimes you get some books
to blurb or something like that
and I'm like, I'm just
not going to do it.
Because I only want
to read exactly what
I want to read at
this exact moment.
Sometimes I go into bookstores
and say to the person there,
this is what I'm thinking about.
A great book store
clerk will just be--
a great bookseller will just
be like, right, you want this,
this--
here, I'm putting
this in your hand.
This is the thing
that you want to read.
And sometimes they're right
and sometimes they're wrong.
But they're going to
expose you to ideas
that you haven't had before.
Or I don't know.
I have writer friends, too.
And I just say, send me a list.
This is what I'm thinking
about, send me a list.
And then I just go
through and just read.
But with this, it was
actually really tailored
because I was reading memoirs.
Because I wanted this to
feel not like a memoir,
but memoiristic.
And so I was reading
different memoirs
that had unconventional
structures or styles
and were really strong in voice.
I read M Train by Patti Smith,
and I read The Argonauts
by Maggie Nelson, and I read
Chelsea Girls by Eileen Myles.
Those were kind
of the three that
stand out in my
mind as influential
as I was writing this.
JAIME GREEN: Cool.
Well, I think that's
all the time we have,
so thank you so
much for coming in.
JAMI ATTENBERG:
Thanks for having me.
[APPLAUSE]